you would never think it but this small
toy gun from the 90s helped create one
of the most iconic and devastating
weapons in gaming history The BFG 9000
[Music]
The BFG 9000 is an iconic part of Jim's
identity as recognizable as the super
shotgun or doom guys form-fitting
forest-green armor but how exactly did
Toys R Us purchase in the early 90s lead
to one of the most quintessential of all
video game weapons well to fully
understand that story join us as we
track the evolution of The BFG from this
to this BFG 9000 was based on
photographs of the very gun you see in
my hands the worgen originally found in
a 1990s Toys R Us with light-up flash
and make all sorts of noise in the real
world but in the world of doom it became
the biggest of big [ __ ] guns if you
take a look at this image of the same
gun add a little rotation a mirror
effect you can start to see the elements
that make up the BFG even more so when
you overlay the in games right on top
when you see these images merge you can
start to imagine what its software we're
working with as they designed their
iconic weapon while you may think it's
odd that it's software found the
inspiration for The BFG at the home of
Jeffrey the giraffe it actually makes a
lot of sense when you think about the
popularity of toy guns in the late 80s
and early 90s huge franchises like Rambo
The Terminator series predator and even
aliens all had their own toy lines and
the industrial futuristic aesthetics of
their weaponry provided vibrant
inspirations for the doom team surfer a
games development studio looking to
experiment with a new way of building
assets using real-world objects these
toys takes all of their boxes they had
the right look and feel the simplistic
designs and shapes made them easy to
digitize but they were also cheap and
finding them was as simple as driving to
the mall with the BFG 9000 s humble
design origins established the very
first appearance of the weapon would be
in the original dooms beta known as The
BFG 2704 in the doom Bible which is what
the original games design document was
known as the edge rereads BFG 2704 red
horrible hallway scouring weapon damages
user a bit or for recoil BFG stands for
big and gun safest use back to wall
distant target the BFG fired a rapid
stream of green and red plasma
projectiles which could bounce around
the environment continuing to do damage
to the demons caught in their wake
however with a number of sprites on
screen the weapon could cause the game
to slow down and according to John
Romero the red and green plasma sprites
looked a bit too Christmasy so the
design was scrapped in favor of the big
green energy blasts we now associate
with the BFG 9000
[Music]
when dreamers released in 1993 the
earliest players could get their hands
on the weapon was in a third mission of
the third episode pandemonium being the
last and most powerful firearm that doom
guy could bring to bear it was
understandably saved for the latter
parts of the game where cyber demons and
spite of masterminds demand more
ordnance to dispose off in Doom - the
weapon remained unchanged instead simply
continuing its legacy of reducing
enemies to a crimson paste and while The
BFG received a facelift three years
later in Doom 64 it still retained the
course cyberdemon melting power the
weapon was known for well you know what
they say if you're glowing green
superweapon ain't broke don't fix it it
wasn't until June 3 when we really got a
new version of The BFG to play with for
this version there were some changes
from previous titles like having
separate ammunition rather than being
forced to share rounds of the plasma
rifle and having a charged option for a
more powerful shot
in my opinion the best thing it did for
Doom 3 was bring the game back to its
old-school sheet of roots doom 3 felt
more like a horror game than a shooter
it was dark at jump scares and forced
you to ditch weapons in order to hold a
flashlight and the whole experience was
much more slow and deliberate than what
Doom was known for that is however until
you got to the final act of the game
where both demons and ammunition was
plentiful your arsenal was overflowing
and you could let loose with much more
reckless abandon than you could in
previous hours of playing that was where
the game felt like dooms of old and that
was where the BFG was most at home big
hordes of demons disappearing under a
green glow at the pull of a trigger the
appearance of The BFG 9000 in doom 2016
however is still a moment that fills me
with excitement and an urge to rip and
tear even four years later this is a
game encapsulate the energy of Doom and
wears it proudly on its sleeve as soon
as you get through to the highly secured
BFG you're immediately thrown into a
situation for you to make the most of
its destructive power a room full of
enemies to Jib as the hammering tones of
Mick Gordon's BFG division begin to
pound through your speakers
[Music]
it is a moment that distills the BFGS
legacy in a concentrated stream of
intensity motion and simulated violence
it's with this reason that I would
revert to checkpoint and replay the
moment again and again it's satisfying
and rewarding on so many levels as a
technically impressive set piece a story
beats and as a moment to really engage
that primal part of your brain that
takes so much enjoyment in seeing stuff
blow up the first time I played through
this section I didn't realize that my
heart was so high or that I was holding
in such a deep breath until I heard the
soothing tones of a computerized voice
echo while I think we all knew that the
BFG 9000 would return and doom eternal
it wasn't until III 2019 that we got our
first glimpse at its famous green glow
as its span up against a cyberdemon in
an utter tease as the screen cuts to
black before the shot is unleashed in
the lead-up to eternal is also the first
time we got to see the real in universe
successor to the big gun in the form of
the Phobos planetary cannon The BFG
10,000
the legacy of The BFG though cannot be
contained to the hellscape doom it
became an icon when the FPS genre was
still in its formative years where
dozens of doom clones attempted to
replicate the visceral experience
through their own settings and weapons
and would continue to appear in other in
software game 1997's quake 2 featured a
nod to the weapon with its own BFG 10k
which works in a similar way to the doom
versions quake 3 had a weapon with the
same name but instead shoots a
rapid-fire explosive projectiles similar
to Jim's plasma rifle is present in the
bizarre 2005 mobile game doom RPG in the
doom tabletop game is an action car that
can even all all defense and dodges in
the dream comic our green marine hero
actually weeps when he acquires it but I
was hired as June fans wept during its
appearance in the terrible doom movie as
the bio force gun version 3.1 for
[Music]
Caudill a terrible name
2011 s rage introduced a weapon called
the authority pulse cannon
whose secondary fire used in alternate
ammunition type called pfg rounds and it
even appeared in 2019 s rage to where
you could find a familiar facsimile the
weapon assuming you have the special
addition to game and had synced up your
professor account now one of the reasons
this weapon is so legendary is down to
the sheer number of times has been
referenced in movies TV shows video
games and even beyond honestly the only
way I'm gonna get through them is if I
rattle them off rapid fire mode the 2004
PC RPG sacred had an attack called BFG
Ratchet and Clank up your arsenal had a
level called the nefarious BFG a 2005
criterion software shoot of black
references the m249 machine gun as the
BFG globally popular mobile league of
legends has an item named the BF sword
although not to be outdone blizzards own
MOBA hair as the storm has a character
named sergeant hammer whose ultimate
ability is the blunt force gun indie
roguelike and the gungeon has a weapon
known as the BSG leg shoot a gun that
acts like the BFG 9000 half-life
opposing force is a weapon called the
displacer cannon that seemingly works in
the same way as the BFG it was a Magic
the Gathering expansion pack in 1998
that featured a B F M or big furry
monster a creature that was so big it
took up two cards the largest can of the
energy drink monks
that used to be able to buy was called
the B F scene according to an interview
with GQ Elon Musk's internal names for
the space X's and Mars Rockets are known
as the PFR and the BFS big rocket and
big in spaceship
it's amazing to think that the BFG 9000
has become such an iconic weapon within
games considering where it came from
this simple toy gun went on to inspire
one of the most revered virtual
artifacts in gaming history now did the
original it team think that the design
would become such an impactful source of
inspiration and parody I don't think
they're plans with that grandiose in
fact I think the simplest explanation is
the most likely that they just wanted to
make a big [ __ ] gun thank you so much
for watching our little love letter to
the BFG 9000 if you enjoyed make sure
you like the video leave your thoughts
in the comment section down below and if
you new here make sure you go back and
watch the other episodes of loadout
there are already on our YouTube channel